okay so i'm going to go ahead and turn
this over to eric and he's going to take
you through the datasets command line
tool so take it away eric
all right thank you peter
thanks everybody for coming today uh
welcome to the webinar on using datasets
command line tools to download and use
genome metadata
so here's an outline of the webinar
today
first i'm going to introduce the data
sets project
then our command line tools and then i'm
going to go over two examples of using
our command line tools
so first i'm going to show you one way
to get high quality butterfly genomes
and then i'm going to show you how to
find sars kobe 2 lambda variant genomes
so the butterfly genome example will
hopefully give you some general ideas
about how you can get genome metadata
and sequence data for really any
organism
while the cyrus cov2 example is a little
bit more specifically focused on
sargeras cov2 data
so datasets is a relatively new effort
at ncbi that's focused on making
sequence data easy to find and download
we have web pages including our home
page shown here
command line tools that i'm going to
talk about today and a documented public
rest api
a big emphasis of the project is
providing easier access to genome data
including genome sequence
genome annotation
and transcript and protein sequences
so today's presentation is just focused
on
access accessing genome data using our
command line tools
so as i said we're looking at two
examples of using our command line tools
in both examples we'll use the data sets
tool
this is for downloading biological
sequence data
and in the second example we'll also
talk about data format
which is used to generate human readable
metadata tables
we don't have time today to go over
installing the tools but you can
download them from the data sets website
and we've recently made them available
through conda
we're also going to use two other
third-party tools
mostly jq
and we'll also touch a little bit on
samtools jq is a great tool for working
with json formatted data
the dataset's command line tool delivers
metadata in two flavors of json json and
json lines
so just a quick note about
versions
today we're talking about version 12 of
the datasets command line tools
these are expected to remain stable for
the foreseeable future
and these are based on version one
of our api
and at the moment we're starting
development on api version two which
will power future releases of the
command line tools
and we're planning a lot of new features
and some breaking changes
this is a great time to give us feedback
on where we'll be going next as we start
planning
version two of the api
so for the first example
we're going to download metadata
describing butterfly genomes
then use information in this metadata to
help us identify and download a subset
of high quality genomes
we're going to use a built-in filter to
get butterfly genomes at the chromosome
assembly level
then we're going to further restrict
this set of chromosome level butterfly
genome assemblies
to those above a certain contig n50
value
along the way we'll show you how to get
genome metadata how to convert genome
metadata into human readable formats
how you can filter the metadata and
finally how to download a set of genome
assemblies
so we're going to start by downloading
genome metadata for all butterflies so
we're going to go ahead and switch to
the terminal window now
okay so
one way to get
genome metadata is by using the data
sets
summary command
so i'm going to go through each part of
the command and describe what it means
so data set summary means that we are
going to get
metadata
genome specifies the type of metadata
and taxon tells you what kind of query
you're going to use to get this genome
metadata so this can be a taxonomic name
or an ncbi taxonomy id
in this case we're just going to use the
name butterflies
the assembly source
parameter allows you to specify whether
you want data for either genbank or
refseq assemblies
today we're just going to look at
genbank assemblies to keep things simple
and we're going to run this command and
save the output to a file
butterflysummary.json
so let's start with a simple question
about this metadata
how many genomes
are there
so here's one way to get the genome
count
we're going to use jq to print pretty
print the data to make it easier to read
and then we're going to pipe this to
tail to show the last 10 lines of this
pretty printed data
because the genome count is always shown
at the end of the genome metadata that
you get using the summary command this
command will let you see the number of
butterfly genomes described by the
metadata
as you can see here it just shows total
count
562 so that means there's 562 genomes
another way to get the genome count is
to specify the name of this total count
field and using the power of jq just
pull the value out directly
so here we just run jq and specify the
field name total count
and the file name
and then you'll just get that that
genome count back directly
so
since we're looking for high quality
butterfly genomes we can use the
assembly level filter to only get
chromosome level
butterfly genome assemblies
so we're going to run this summary
command again
but this time we'll use two filters
one filter
to get genbank assemblies
and one filter to get chromosome level
assemblies
okay so we've saved that metadata to a
file butterfly chromelevel.json
and now we're going to use
jq
specifying the the field name of total
count to see how many genomes
how many butterfly genomes are at the
chromosome assembly level
so you can see that number is a lot
smaller than what we had before
so we've reduced the set of genomes from
from almost 600 genomes to less than 50.
so it's great when you need to filter by
some attribute where we already have a
built-in filter like assembly level or
assembly source
you also have filters to only get
annotated genomes or get genomes
released before or after a certain date
but sometimes you might need to filter
by other attributes of a genome record
where we don't have built-in filters
available
so i'll show you how to do that using jq
um people often use contagion 50 value
as a measure of genome quality
so to further narrow down our set of
butterfly genomes
we're going to take the list of
chromosome level butterfly genome genome
assemblies we already have
and then only keep the genomes where the
contig n50 value is over 1.5 million
so i'm going to show you how to make a
simple table of assembly accessions and
contig and 50 values
using
jq
so basically what this command is saying
is
take this metadata describing the
chromosome level butterfly assemblies
send it to jq
and then for each assembly
give me back the
assembly accession
and the cont n50 value
and then generate a tab delimited table
in tsv format
and then
i'm going to pipe that to head
to just show the first five rows of that
table
so now you have this this two column
table the first column has
assembly accessions second column shows
you the contig and 50 values
so next
we're going to get the genomic sessions
for those genomes with a contig and 50
value over 1.5 million
so again we're sending the metadata for
all chromosome level butterfly genome
assemblies to jq
then this jq command is saying for all
assemblies in the set
just give me back the assemblies with
the contig n50 value
over 1.5 million
and then for each of those assemblies
just give me the assembly accession
so this is this is the whole list of
butterfly genome assemblies that are
both
chromosome level assemblies with
contagion 50 values over 1.5 million
and in case you're curious where these
genomes came from these are all from the
darwin tree of life project
which is a project to try and sequence
70 000 eukaryotes from britain and
ireland
so next we're going to save this list to
a file
so i'm just going to run that same
command again
and save it to a file called accession
list
now that we have this list of assembly
accessions we can download the genome
sequences for these genomes
so this this takes a few minutes so i've
already downloaded it in advance
but i'm going to show you the command
that i used
so this is what the download command
looks like
i'm going to go through each part of the
command and explain what it means
this says
download genome data
given one or more
accessions
in this case we're using a text file
with the list of accessions we generated
previously
to specify which genomes we want
so then why do you need all these
exclude flags
so
datasets delivers our sequence and
annotation data in a zip archive that we
call a data package
by default these packages will include a
bunch of different types of sequence
data
annotation data and metadata
so for example for an annotated
eukaryotic genome
we would include the genome sequence
transcript and protein sequences
annotation in gff3 format
and metadata in one or more files we
call data reports
so if you only want to get genome
sequence
you can add various exclude flags to
for example exclude the protein sequence
exclude the annotation file
and exclude the rna or transcript
sequences
so let's take a quick look at what's in
this downloaded package of genome
sequence
i'm going to use the tree command to
show you
the directory structure and some of the
files that are included in the download
package
so
as i said i've already downloaded the
zip archive and extracted it on my
computer
we're going to run tree on this
directory that's containing that
contains the contents of that zip
archive and then pipe that to less so we
can scroll through that
output
so you'll notice that
data for each genome assembly is in a
directory that's named with that
assembly accession
so in this case we ask for just genome
sequence so you'll see
fasta files in each of these directories
representing each assembled chromosome
sequences from unplaced and unlocalized
sequences are in separate files
and in each directory representing a
genome assembly there's a sequence
report file that's basically a list of
all the sequences that comprise the
assembly
and then if you scroll all the way down
to the bottom
you'll see the assembly data report
which describes
all the genome assemblies that are
included in this
package
so that's the end of the first example
okay so next we're going to talk about
cyrus cov2 genomes
so this example is
focused on cyrus cov2 genome data we'll
show you how to download genome data and
view and filter the associated metadata
specifically we'll show you how to pull
out cyrus cov2 genome metadata and
sequence data for one cyrus covu2
lineage to lambda variant of interest
so first i'll show you how to download
data for all sars cov2 genomes
so
this is the command you'd use to
download all stars cov2 genomes
we're now up to over 1.5 million genomes
so this download can take a little while
depending on your internet connection
for the purpose of today's demo we're
going to use a smaller package of sars
kobe ii genomes
that were released during a three-day
period last week which contains just
about 65 000 genomes
so i've already downloaded the zip file
and extracted the zip archive
so we're going to use tree again
to take a look at what's inside
what i've downloaded
so
you'll see there's just a few files in
the data directory
compared to
that genome data package that we
downloaded in the last example
i just want you to pay attention to two
files here
there's the data report
that includes metadata and annotation
data for each viral genome
and genomic
dot fna includes all 65 000 genome
sequences
so now i'm going to introduce the other
command line tool that we've developed
it's called data format this is
specifically for generating tables
based on the metadata
in this data report file here
so we'll go through each part of this
command and what it means so data format
is the name of the tool
tsv means we want the output to be a tab
delimited table
and fires genome specifies the type of
data report we'll be using as input
we'll use the
input file parameter to specify
the path to the data report itself
and then we'll use fields to specify
all the columns that we want to include
in our table
so here we're including
isolate lineage which is an identifier
for the genome record accession is the
ncbi nucleotide accession
geolocation is the geographic location
where the virus was isolated
isolate collection date is when it was
found
and virus pangolin is the pango lineage
name that we've calculated for that
genome
and then we're going to use head just to
show the first five rows of that table
so
you can see there's
four genomes here
it's a little bit hard to read the last
column is kind of going over the next
row
but if you've looked at these
pango lineages before you might
recognize this
b16172
as the so-called
delta variant
next we're going to pull out metadata
for all sars cov2 genomes representing
just the lambda variant of interest
so one thing you should know about our
data reports is that each line of the
data report represents a single record
where in this case a single stars cov2
genome
so this allows you to use grep with an
identifier other string to pull out all
the metadata for a particular genome
containing that identifier
so in this case we want to get all the
metadata for the lambda variant of
interest genomes
we don't have the who term lambda in our
data reports but we do have the pango
lineage names and for lambda that's c37
so we'll grab for c37 to pull out the
metadata for those lambda variant
genomes
and then we'll save that to a file
lambda.jsonl
so now let's use
this taking a little bit longer than
expected
there we go
all right
now we're going to use data format and
take a look at the metadata we've saved
so we're going to basically run the same
data format command that we just ran
but now we're going to use this
new file that we've generated as the
input file
so let's see what that looks like
all right you can see that if you look
in this last column you can see now we
only have the the lambda variant genomes
or the c37 genomes
next i'm going to show you how we can
use data format and sam tools
to pull out the genome sequences for
these lambda variant genomes
so first we'll use data format to get
the accessions only from our metadata
file then we'll use that list of
accessions to specify which genome
sequences to pull out of our genome
sequence
file so first
we'll use data format again
this time we'll specify just a single
field accession to get a single column
table of accessions only
and we're also going to use the
elide header
flag to remove the column name
which could cause problems with samtools
so i'll just show you what the first
five
accessions looks like
okay now we're going to go ahead and
save that list as a file
lambda accessions
now we're going to use samtools to
extract the lambda sequences from the
original genomic
fasta file that we downloaded as part of
the package
so here is the samtools
command we're using
we're going to specify the
file with the accession list
this is
the original genomic sequence file
and then we're going to save the output
as lambdagenomes.fna
all right and then
let's see
what you can do with that file
okay
we're gonna just drag and drop
that fasta sequence file into the next
clade
website
you can give it a few seconds
this gives kind of a nice way to to
visualize these genomes
and it's nice to see that they've also
identified these as lambda variant
genomes
and this kind of gives you a nice
visualization of other mutations that
are present in genomes and
some ideas about genome quality
and that concludes the second example
so i think we're um we can take some
questions
hi eric thanks um that was great uh
there's a few questions um
one
there was a little bit of discussion
about um
installing this on a cluster and i
wanted brad to comment on that because
he had a couple of thoughts about that
brad are you there
at home yeah happy to speak to that
um
so i i'll be honest i'm not uh we have a
different kind of cluster here and in
our case we'd be responsible for either
every time we submit a job
ensuring that the app gets installed
from conda or
through some direct download link the
quick starts link there that's
also in the answer
um so that's that's one option or you
can talk to the systems and say look we
want this sort of globally installed
just like you install
any other package and they could follow
the similar steps to ensure it's
available on every machine
so i think the answers kind of sort of
vary on what the administrators want to
do with the cluster
okay and you had sort of had some you
had some comments about rape too um
oh thanks yeah sorry so yeah that's the
other thing is um
there
these tools are rate limited um
it's possible to get an api key we're
working on uh setting up api keys
uh through my ncbi which would allow a
slightly higher rate
but we do not ever intend to support
like 400 concurrent connections
uh from the same api key
all you know downloading a package so it
would be bad practice to say all right
well i want to start 400 jobs and they
all go download you know a million
sequences the same million sequences and
they sort of in parallel operate on that
package
uh be better practice to have a single
task to first go get that package of
data
and then send that data out to the 400
jobs or as some
however you share data on your cluster
and they can then operate on the same
package
uh if if we do see sort of uh
you know service is going to degrade if
there's that many concurrent connections
coming in
okay thanks brad
another question that was here is about
downloading by accession that version
and brad chatted to me that he didn't
think that was possible so
um
eric do you have any comments on that
in other words can you just specify the
access i think this is what the person
wanted to know like can you just give it
an accession.version and use
datasets that download something that
way
uh you can only for
with assembly accessions
genome assembly accessions but you can't
do that yet for um sardis kobe two
genomes
you can also download uh gene data by
refseq uh exception.versions
good point
but yeah the question came in while we
were looking at viruses and and so in
terms of virus genomic refseq accession
there's not a way to access that data if
that that's useful we'd like to know
okay and there was another um
well here's a couple more that have come
in but one of them was
had to do with how quickly sequences
that are submitted i think is what the
question is really about how quickly
they're turned around so when we're
talking about cyrus kobe 2 do we have
any
and this may be a question for another
group at ncbi and if it is i'll get the
answer from them too but
how quickly does a sequence get from
being submitted to being available in
data sets for the source code ii
sequences
hi i can i can answer that um so
when the sequences get submitted to
genbank
they then get picked up by ncbi virus if
you're aware of that resource
and we pull them from ncbi virus so
um
brad may be able to comment on exactly
how long it takes but
we do update our virus
data set every day
so we should pick up anything that's new
in ncbi virus and i believe that that
also gets updated every day for every or
a couple of times a day
and now brad if you have any more
information on that
i don't yeah it's uh it's so many
factors involved how quickly the labs
turn over the data how quickly it goes
through our submission system how many
other submissions we receive the same
day
well we're working to get it out as fast
as possible uh 24 hours is certainly
possible
uh but there are no guarantees on that
and then somebody asks a question that
um it's probably worth addressing you
know you mentioned that there are 1.5
million
genomes for cyrus kobe 2. and the
question is are they all unique or are
they duplicate sequences isolated from
different individuals oh and brad sort
of answered that but
they're basically different samples
they're all unique submissions the
sequence could be identical right
video submission is unique
yeah okay and there was another question
that um
just a general one about how to find out
about
webinars and workshops like this and
bret um
eric did we have that did you have that
slide at the end that had the sort of
links to the social media and things
like that i don't know if we kept that
in your slides that are not
yes here we go
yeah so yeah just just to point out to
you that
you know we have social media presence
and um
you know
we announce all these things on social
media so on twitter on facebook and on
linkedin
we also have a blog um in cvi insights
and so if you go to that a blog and then
you're a wordpress if you have wordpress
account you can subscribe to that blog
as well
there's also a an old-fashioned email
list that somebody asked about and
that's the
the ncbi
announce email list so if that's
something you want i can put the
url and the chat to everybody and that's
how to get to that if you want to
subscribe to that email list
okay and i don't i think we covered all
the questions that we have in the
chat right now
uh and if there's any that we didn't get
to um
answer
i'll make sure that they're in the
document
so thanks everybody for coming and
thanks brad newell and eric for
being here
thank you okay thanks a lot